au début des années 2000 face au
ralentissement des marchés occidental
lafarge décide de s'installer au
moyen-orient et notamment en syrie
goûter 2008 le groupe français a investi
près de 700 millions de dollars pour
l'achèvement de la plus grande
cimenterie du pays à jabaliya au nord de
jaca l'usiné est terminée fin 2010 soit
pas de chance quelques mois avant le
début de la crise syrienne
très vite la région est le théâtre de
combats entre diverses factions armées
kurde armée syrienne libre groupe
islamiste face à la situation toutes les
entreprises françaises quittent le pays
en 2012 tout
non car une usine peuplé d'irréductibles
cimentier résiste aux groupes rebelles
enfin résistent ou achète sa
tranquillité dès le mois de juillet
lafarge versent des bakchichs à des
intermédiaires pour assurer la sécurité
de ses employés et le libre passage de
ces camions des sommes allant de
quelques dizaines de milliers à plus de
cent mille euros par mois maquiller dans
les comptes de la société
en notes de frais du directeur de la
filiale syrienne de lafarge mais qui ne
suffiront pas à protéger les employés
puisque neuf d'entre eux sont prises en
otage par les kurdes en octobre 2012
avant d'être relâchés contre une rançon
de 200 mille euros un épisode qui n'a
apparemment pas marqué les mémoires
dédiées les gens ont géré les risques
par cette économie de raquette et il n'y
a pas eu de phénomène marquant jusqu'à
fin 2013
et si vous vous demandez pourquoi
lafarge s'est obstiné à rester en syrie
alors que tous sont partis voici les
réponses des responsables du groupe
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
lorsque cette guerre a commencé lusine
venait de démarrer
on pensait que quand tout serait fini il
y aurait au moins une cimenterie qui
pourrait fournir du ciment pour
reconstruire la syrie début 2013 la
situation empirera cas tombe aux mains
des islamistes du front alnot sera
claude hêche qui en prend le contrôle en
juin sans que cela ne remette en
question la présence de lafarge en syrie
déj s'inscrit dans le paysage
il affiche la volonté de taxer les
routes le rac étage de neige c'était
l'équivalent de 500 tonnes sachant qu'on
a trois silos de 20 mille tonnes
est-ce qu'on va tout plié pour 500
tonnes on estime que lafarge aura au
total versé 15
millions de dollars en pots-de-vin à des
groupes terroristes dont des shows
jusqu'à la taille de l'usiné de ge à la
bia par ces derniers en septembre 2014
des largesses qui valent tant 2018 à la
société d'être mise en examen pour
financement d'une entreprise terroriste
et complicité de crime contre l'humanité
une première historique pour une
personne morale lafarge doit aussi
répondre de deux autres chefs
d'inculpation violation d'un embargo et
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
autant d'accusations face auquel le
cimentier ferait bien d'opposer une
défense en béton